let's play a little fill in the blanks
chris and let's begin with this
one topic that is very near and dear to
my heart and a drum that i bang every
year at this time blank
had the best draft of any nfl team in
the year 2020 go well i think i'm gonna
go to the baltimore ravens is the team
that jumps out to me i mean when i just
look at what the baltimore ravens did
again for the second straight draft
i just come away going man they're just
one of those teams that you know
again we could just go everybody's
playing checkers and they seem to be
playing chess just on another level the
way they operate through free agency and
the draft but to get a starting big time
middle linebacker and patrick queen in
round one then to get jk dobbins in
round two i mean one of the most
explosive running backs in the draft 80
yard touchdown type of machine to have
him to go along with that o-line and of
course the lamar jackson running good
defensive tackle from texas a m i mean
baltimore shocker they collect the
biggest baddest dudes on the planet
every year get a strong physical
receiver out of my school texas and
devin durnay uh duvernay excuse me and
then get another thumping middle
linebacker because they have an issue
there and malik harrison from ohio state
so i look at the baltimore ravens as
being that team there was a few others
in the mix the carolina panthers i love
it but i just think the ravens have
killed the off season to this point and
killed the draft once again uh this past
weekend
and given the history of the ravens
they're competitive almost every year
you never see them go five and eleven
four and twelve they're always in the
mix eric decosta's done a great job
before that ozzie newsome did a
spectacular job he could get a bust in
the hall of fame separate and apart from
the one he earned as a player but chris
i keep coming back to the one thing and
i if i'm the only voice out there that
will say this after the draft that's
fine with me
we don't know who had the best draft in
2020 no we don't know and we won't know
it's all a crapshoot and that's the one
thing that i would love to see more of
in the draft coverage but we won't ever
see it and hear it because
there's no way that the draft experts
can tell us which of these guys is going
to be a bust they can say hey you know
what half these guys aren't going to
work out round one half of these guys
are going to stink instead of hyping up
every pick hey you know what half of
these guys are gonna stink here's the
big caveat half of these guys aren't
gonna make it they're never gonna say
that because if they say that number one
it undermines this effort to sell hope
to all the fans that every fan thinks
they're one draft away from hatching a
dynasty in their local town but the
other side of it too is if we're too
candid about the fact that half these
guys are going to not work out and then
people want to know since we're the
experts which half we don't know and at
a certain point they say well why the
hell are we listening but that's the
truth we don't know we don't know i
remember seeing the draft grades for the
seahawks after the 2012 draft d minus f
plus right okay they got bobby wagner
and russell wilson in that draft yeah d
minus c plus my butt but the thing is we
don't know what the time we won't know
and that's the beauty of this for all
the time and effort that they put into
it nobody knows what the hell these guys
are going to do until yeah but we do
know sometimes sometimes we know
sometimes we we come away going man they
had a great draft and then we go to the
season and we go damn those guys that we
thought had a great draft have been a
great during the season you're right but
it's about potential
it's about potential you're absolutely
right and it's about what happens when
it's time to go line up and get hit hard
by a grown ass man everyone's got a
ceiling between what they did in college
and the nfl or slash pro football hall
of fame we don't know what that ceiling
is and nobody knows what that ceiling is
and we all find out in real time when
you throw all these guys in the blender
with the guys who've been playing in the
nfl for the last five 10 15 years and
that's part of the fun of it you figure
out who has it and who doesn't so we
don't know is my answer next one the
quarterback drafted after round one who
will start a game first is who i i just
can't believe your answer still i'm
going with the we don't know answer to
start it off you're gonna talk you could
have we don't
no that's the truth we can lie and act
like we do know i prefer to be authentic
and honest with the audience and
transparent and say we don't know
because you know that's the truth
well i i don't yeah to a degree i think
that's the truth i'm not going to no say
that's the total truth no i do know i've
been around a lot of times and i've been
right a whole lot of time so we'll see
general manager chris sims we'll see
okay okay bullcrap artist on monday
filling the blank show good job
all right here we go you ready
that's our last show hey welcome london
how are you good to have you in today if
you had april
27 on the uh pool as to when will be
canceled because of chris's mouth uh
congratulations go cash your ticket all
right all right quarterback drafted
after round one who will start a game
first is who
okay i go down to two guys here i mean
one would be james morgan for the new
york jets uh and i'm sorry i swear i
don't mean to make you mad almighty
master michael florio uh i look at him
dad i'm just i'm just i'm just i'm just
projecting what the rest of my day is
going to be like that's
i okay i'm sorry uh but either way i
look at james morgan or jake lewton for
the jacksonville jaguars to be one of
those two guys i think if you make me
pick though i'm gonna give it go with
jake lewton the sixth round pick from
jacksonville out of oregon state they
don't necessarily have a backup
quarterback situation there in
jacksonville he's kind of nfl ready
schooled that way so if i gotta pick one
i'll pick him right now it was between
him or james morgan for the jets mike
because i think the other guys are gonna
be on the back burner for a little while
i think it's gonna be jalen hurts
because jalen hurts is the number two
quarterback now behind a quarterback who
gets hurt all the time carson wentz it's
that simple it's not about who's gonna
earn it it's about who's gonna start a
game and the eagles drafted jalen hurts
in round two in large part because they
know by now after five years of living
with carson wentz they know that there's
a good chance on any given sunday he's
going to emerge from the game unable to
continue to play so jalen hurts to me is
the guy who's going to be do you think
they throw him out there though if that
happened this year you know what i mean
that's what i would question just
because they haven't seen them
they have nate sutfield
jalen hurts is a little project that's
the only reason i didn't pick him i
certainly recognized the talent and the
thought but that was the reason i didn't
pick and pick him
nate sutfeld's got to emerge from the
preseason healthy something he didn't do
last year so that's his hurdle before
he's in a position to start
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports